die leute ganz kurz bevor ihr euch das
video zeige mit dem ich liebe skate
wurde
ich stelle mir heute 19 uhr fordert live
auftritt also checkt man in erster linie
eine beschreibung abkommt rumpold etwas
zu essen sondern sehen uns vielleicht
ist dann ja mal was ganz besonderes und
zwar zeige ich euch das video mit dem
ich nicht asyl beworben habe und dieses
video hat dann wie gesagt dass ich sein
kater wurde dazu gehe ich jetzt erstmal
in das a-team einer videos hier auf
youtube dieses video habe ich selber
schon ewig nicht mehr gesehen und das
video ist auch komplett privat also das
hat noch keiner irgendwie öffentlichkeit
gesehen
deswegen scroll ich mache hier nach
unten durch alle videos die ich bisher
so hochgeladen habe dass es irgendwie
ganz am anfang meiner youtube karriere
und das ist das zweite video was auf
diesem kanal hochgeladen wurde und ihr
seht schon dieses videos auf nicht
gelistet gestellt das heißt quasi das
können nur leute sehen die diesen link
von mir geklickt haben vollbild und da
schauen wir mal rein
[Musik]
hier also ganz kurze anmerkung das ist
von der musik video hier das ich gemacht
habe für einen kumpel und es sollte
quasi jetzt hier so aussehen als würde
er in der wüste gehen
und ja so sieht das passiert nach heraus
und so saß davor aus nicht einfach in
der sandgrube gewesen und haben das
alles gedreht habe ich den quasi
komplett ausgeschnitten habe diese
wochen in den hintergrund 3d animiert
und hier ist es gleiche spiel
irgendwie kommt mir ausgeschnitten und
gemerkt dass vielleicht schon das wieder
das gar nicht mal so viel mit liebe
direkt zu tun ich habe das video hat
weil sie einfach nur zusammen gestellt
dass man zusammensteht aus all den
sachen nicht weil sie geleistet habe und
gearbeitet haben und die haben zusammen
geschnitten und hat dann quasi die
risiken und gesagt hey das kann ich und
das hat ihm gefallen war
ihr seht ihr links unten übrigens auch
immer das datum wann das gemacht wurde
das war im mai 2016 also folgt drei
jahren jetzt schon da war ich noch 17
und zu seiner 3d animierte spinne die
habe ich 3d modelliert und dann habe ich
die quasi animiert und dann quasi auf
diese steine drauf gesetzt die bei uns
zu hause in bayern im hinterhof sind er
sieht jetzt gleich so einen kleinen
breakdown wie das gemacht wurde und das
finde ich ziemlich geil
ja hier noch die farbe ihr seht es
geschichten die ich gemacht habe hier
schon blöd dass es bewegungsunschärfe
die ich noch drauf gemacht haben ist
natürlicher wirkt hier tiefenunschärfe
das quasi die sachen die weiter weg von
der kundschaft sind und die sachen die
er dem focus
scharf sind und was ich echt hässlich
finde ich finde das was in dieser
bewerbung ist das habe ich zwar vor drei
jahren gemacht aber es sind halt
trotzdem schon ziemlich krass im
vergleich zu der arbeit ich jetzt
momentan machen momentan will ich
natürlich leute unterhalten und halt
hier konnten bringen und halt möglichst
ein oder zweimal die woche irgendwas
machen und das geht mit auffälligen im
zeugnis ist halt wie sie schwierig weil
aber ich glaube für diesen schrott
allein habe ich damals zwei wochen
gebraucht und heute wird es natürlich
schneller schaffen aber ja so damals
habe ich da auch ein bisschen gelernt
und hier ist ein volk gewonnen
dazu habe ich ja später noch mal ein
video gemacht mit pokémon
das hieraus stecken könnte und das ist
ein ultra geiler schott also das ist
auch in der musik video und ihr seht ja
quasi dass er hier auch zum felsen sitzt
und im hintergrund das meer ist was
jetzt gleich passiert also ich glaube
damit hat nie irgend jemand gerechnet
als ich denen das video gezeigt habt
guckt einfach mal selber hin
das war nämlich gar nicht immer mehr
sondern einfach über irgendeinem kaff
ich habe ihn quasi einfach mal wenn ihr
hier auf seine füße einmal komplett bild
für bild ausgeschnitten und allein
dieser schott hat drei tage gedauert so
ja das war dann quasi mal ein
bewerbungsvideo was ich quasi andré wie
geschickt hatte daraufhin hat sich dann
die kiddies managerin bei mir gemeldet
und gesagt hey wie würde sich gerne mal
mit treffen und dich einfliegen
ich bin ich trotzdem sauber eingefahren
ich habe ja mal in ihren spaß auf jeden
fall finde es spannend mal diese älteren
video anzugucken ich gehe ja noch mal in
der lustigen videos durch also hier
finden wir können sie dieses musikvideo
mit dem heißt dass aus dem jetzt diese
ganzen ausschnitte gerade so passiert du
deine brüste rumrennt die ja eigentlich
gar keine wüste ist und hier bei diesen
schotter ist ja auch nicht in einem eher
das habe ich einfach im freibad gedreht
wo ich dann ausgeschnitten haben hier
mal doch da habe ich nämlich als ich 15
war habe ich die erstellt also 3d
modellen von pokémon experimentieren und
die hier in dem fall in ein kinderzimmer
am boden animiert und so bisschen
experimentiert ja geisteskrank alter
hier haben wir einen biberach ja hier
haben wir ein bulli war es gleich hier
auf hüpft verfolgt von einem top blogger
das video kam erst 2016 habe ich habe
die sachen schon gemacht als ich 15 war
klar dass es ganz lustig das heim
zusammen mit leon gefilmt hatten da ist
ja sogar leon
das habe ich in berlin gefallen als ich
noch bei relais und gewohnt habe und da
seht ihr jetzt wie ich ja schon ganz
klar jetzt nicht gebeugt preis ganz
witzig das heißt auch dass reinhold
fischer da ist natürlich nie etwas
geworden wäre ja auch noch meine ersten
videos da habe ich aber schon betrieben
zusammen gearbeitet war aber noch nicht
in köln das gute doodle mario world das
ist nämlich auch ziemlich geil geworden
ich finde es waren auch zwei wochen
arbeit damalig quasi einfach mit edding
an die wand und bewegen sich dann so
sachen ich habe das in dem haus und so
viele eltern gemacht und ich fand es gar
nicht so geil dass ich dann muss man die
wand geschmiert haben naja ich echt geil
ich hab ich auch schon selber ich
gemerkt so was muss ich machen
[Musik]
tatsächlich geplant so was immer zu
machen
da ist es dann aber nicht gekommen weil
ja nicht die zeit hatte stark diese sein
gold damaligen geil finde es aber nicht
die algen prinz 1 da habe ich ihn
einfach ausradiert aber natürlich alle
features findet und haben wir natürlich
mal überhaupt so gar nicht happy ja und
da wenn wir jetzt homescreen haben wir
dann auch schon quasi das erste video wo
ich dann mit baby unterwegs war
in namibia genau also ich glaube da ist
rebecca die video
aber da waren wir noch nie jetzt habt
ihr meine bewerbung gesehen die wie
geschickt habt und mit diesem video
wurde ich karte von gewissheit und wenn
ihr bock habt auch mal so schnitt visual
effects zu lernen da kommt ein kurs auf
euch zu ich arbeite daran bzw ich bin
gestern damit fertig geworden da oder
ein bisschen bisher online kommen auf
jeden fall mal auf insel amrum da auf
dem laufenden zu bleiben und wenn ihr
bock habe ich auf diese weise
dann abonniert mich gerne und macht die
glocke an leute und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder
[Musik]